okay
today we will start our discussion of
with the discussion of glycolysis as a
pathway
and how we can use favorable oxidation
of glucose
to enable phosphate addition while at
the same time producing useful
intermediates that
enable us to do atp synthase and
atp synthesis and maintain a high atp
adp ratio
in cells now i drew up here the entire
glycolytic pathway
just like you saw at the end of the last
lecture and i want to go through it here
step by step and so the
first step in glycolysis as we already
talked about is we have
glucose this here is of course alpha
d-glucose in the
uh i drew it in the alpha form if the
o-h was pointing up that would be the
beta form just some quick review
i'll drop the alpha and beta and the
stereochemistry denotion going forward
this glucose molecule as we discussed
previously
is first trapped in cells by being
phosphorylated
by the enzyme hexokinase sometimes
abbreviated hk
to give glucose 6-phosphate
not shown here this glucose 6-phosphate
that undergoes
an isomerase reaction via the open chain
form again we discuss this reaction when
we discuss sugars
and so this would be catalyzed by
glucose phosphate isomerase
and takes it from the aldos to the
ketose so now you have the
fructose the the ketos fructose
6-phosphate
um shown here in the furanose form
this fructose-6-phosphate is then
phosphorylated
a second time by an enzyme called
phosphofructokinase
typically abbreviated pfk it's
phosphorylated
on the one position to give fructose 1
6 bisphosphate shown here
that fructose 1 6 bisphosphate
can then be cleaved by the enzyme
aldolase
cleavage takes place in the open chain
form which i drew
up here in the corner basically
splitting the molecule
in half to form two trioses
one of which is the ketose
dihydroxyacetone
phosphate basically the top half of the
molecule
the other is the bottom half of the
molecule the aldose
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
these two trioses can be interconverted
the
aldos and the ketose via an isomerase
the enzyme that does that is called
trios phosphate
isomerase and moving forward basically
takes the dihydroxyacetone phosphate
that comes from the top half
and can turn all the carbon from
fructose 1 6 bisphosphate
into two glyceraldehyde 3-phosphates
that glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate as we
discussed last time is the substrate for
the gap dh reaction the glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate dehydrogenase gap-d-h
which as we discussed last time couples
oxidation of this aldehyde to this
acid with phosphate addition
that oxidation reaction the electrons
have to go somewhere that's where the
cofactor nad
comes in picks up two electrons
generates nadh
and in the process this enzyme generates
this molecule
one three bisphosphoglycerate or one
three
bpg remember that one three bpg
molecule was one of the useful
intermediates
whereby we could undergo favorable
synthesis
of atp even at the high atp adp ratio
found in cells
and that's because we can transfer the
phosphate from this acid group
um onto adp that gives us an atp
and the product 3-phosphoglycerate or
3pg
carried out by the enzyme
phosphoglycerate kinase
that 3pg molecule can then undergo
what's referred to as a mutase reaction
and so the phosphate is moved from the 3
to the 2 position of glycerate
so 3-phosphoglycerate to
2-phosphoglycerate
carried out by phosphoglycerate mutase
often abbreviated p-gam
this 2-phosphoglycerate can then undergo
a dehydration
to by an enzyme called enolase to give
the molecule
phosphoenolpyruvate phosphoenolpyruvate
was the second
of those useful intermediates that allow
atp synthesis despite the high atp adp
ratio in cells
and that reaction as we already
discussed is carried out by pyruvate
kinase
and allows you to um to
generate another atp
now as i drew out the glycolytic pathway
here
i also listed the delta g naught prime
for
every single step in the reaction
remember this is
informative as to the equilibrium
for each of these individual reactions
you'll note that for many of the steps
that delta g naught prime
is positive remember what that means
that means that equilibrium
favors the left that is the reverse
direction of the entire pathway
however if you add all of these up the
delta g not prime
for the entire pathway so delta
g naught prime for the entire pathway
glucose to pyruvate
adds up to negative
6.9 kcals per mole
and so that negative 6.9 means that for
the entire pathway
equilibrium favors the right
so glucose to pyruvate the right
direction
and that is why this can work
as an overall pathway even though
some of the individual steps equilibrium
may favor
the opposite direction now you'll notice
that there's
several favorable steps where delta g
not prime is
quite negative pyruvate kinase
phosphoglycerate kinase hexokinase
phosphofructokinase
as we talked about before these are able
to pull the less favorable steps
upstream forward by keeping
concentrations of
products such as 1-3 bisphosphoglycerate
low thus allowing this net reaction
to move forward you'll notice i drew
three steps here as
irreversible hexokinase
phosphofructokinase
and pyruvate kinase remember these are
all reactions in are there's no such
thing as an irreversible reaction
there's some conditions
where the reverse reaction of course can
happen
although remember this when we discuss
irreversible and metabolism
what we're referring to is irreversible
under physiological conditions that is
conditions found in cells
you'll notice that those three steps are
three of the four steps that have very
negative
delta g not prime and so you would
expect that if we were going to reverse
those reactions you would need some kind
of
energy input and you'll see later that
these are the control points or also
regulated steps in this pathway
and there are also the sites just to
give you a preview that we're going to
have to deal with
if we're going to try to synthesize
glucose gluconeogenesis the reverse
of glycolysis now
of course these delta g not primes are
very informative of what
happens at equilibrium but of course
what actually happens
in a cell or in any condition remember
is dependent on the equilibrium constant
but also on the conditions remember it's
delta g
delta g equals delta g not prime plus rt
times
the log of the products over the
reactants and so
delta g is what really matters for any
individual reactions
and what's shown here on this slide is
basically
a approximate delta g change
across the glycolytic pathway based on
someone's approximation of the
conditions found in cells
now we can see in looking at this that
there's really three
big drops in delta g across the pathway
here's the hexokinase reaction here's
the phosphofructokinase reaction
here's the pyruvate kinase reaction and
so
it makes sense that these would be then
the irreversible steps because there
is what is actually pulling the pathway
forward it also makes sense that one
would exert control
at each of these steps because this is
what drives the flux of the pathway
forward
but it's also where it's difficult to go
back once you get here on this flat part
of the curve
energetically it doesn't matter so much
which direction you go along the curve
but to try to climb back up each of
these hills becomes difficult
and so we'll revisit this later in the
lecture but this is basically
where the control points will end up
happening
in this pathway now i want to note a
couple
other features about this pathway
and that is is that we had to invest
some energy early you see you cost an
atp
at the hexokinase and the
phosphofructokinase step
and then you harvest that atp much later
at the phosphoglycerate kinase and the
pyruvate
kinase steps the textbook
typically will split glycolysis into
what they refer to as
two stages an investment stage and a
harvesting stage
and that's basically relates to that
fact
and that's because you have a glucose
molecule
that then you use to generate two
trioses okay
and then each of those trioses
can be used to generate
a pyruvate molecule
and so it costs 2 atp
to generate those two trioses but then
each triose generated allows you
to recapture two atps
and so what that means then is that the
net output from glycolysis is
two atps and so glucose
going to two glyceraldehyde
3-phosphates costs you
whereas
using those two glyceraldehyde
three phosphates to generate two
pyruvates
allows you to recover
for atp for a net of
plus 2 atp molecules
produced per glucose metabolized
now if we add up the entire
stoichiometry of what's going on here
we can also draw it another way and that
is we can basically have glucose
plus two adp
molecules plus two inorganic phosphates
goes to two
pyruvates plus two
atp and that's because we're able to
incorporate
two phosphate molecules
here at the gap
dh step now that's great
but if you're paying attention you
notice that we're missing one other
thing in this stoichiometry and that's
that cofactor
nad that was also required
to maintain electron balance across
the gap dh step and so
remember that for this pathways to work
we have to balance all things that are
going in with all things are going out
we can't create or destroy
matter and so those electrons have to be
dealt with
when we discussed the gap dh reaction
last time we needed that cofactor
nad in order to act as an acceptor for
the electrons to allow that
oxidative phosphorylation if you will of
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate to 1
3-bisphosphoglycerate
and so in order for this pathway to work
we need a way to regenerate that nadh
back to an nad in order to make
electron balance in other words we have
to deal with the fact
that we've generated or that we required
two nad plus
to run this pathway and generate two
nadh and so we need a way
to get rid of those
electrons from nadh
to regenerate that nad and allow the
pathway to
be balanced now
it should be clear that this has to
happen
stoichiometrically for every single
glucose molecule
that goes through glycolysis that is we
have to regenerate
two nad pluses for every glucose
that we're going to convert into two
pyruvates
and so for this nad h
reoxidation to occur we need a place to
transfer those two
electron pairs and so just like any
oxidation and reduction reaction if
we're going to
oxidize nadh back to nad plus
something else has to be reduced and
that thing
has to be reduced stoichiometrically
with every single
pyruvate that's produced from glucose
and glycolysis and effectively you will
see
that this is the role of fermentation
it's an ability for us to solve this
redox problem
that we have to dispose of those
electrons
in the oxidation at the gap dh step in
order
to deal with this electron waste of
the pathway now the useful way to do
this
is that we're generating a pyruvate
stoichiometrically and so we can use
that stoichiometrically that that
product
pyruvate by reducing it to form the
waste product
and that's effectively what fermentation
is it's turning that pyruvate into
ethanol or lactate
which is reducing that pyruvate picking
up the electron waste from the nadh
and allowing you to regenerate the nad
that's required to run the gap dh step
and so i'll just illustrate this
the
the simplest fermentation reaction that
we can do
is the run that's done by animals and
that's to generate
lactate and so to just illustrate this
explicitly here is
so this here would be the reduced
form of nad nadh
okay so this here is the
this is the nicotinamide group remember
it's hooked up to an adp
ribose to give nicotinamide adenine
dinucleotide
in the reduced form okay so
this can transfer electrons to
pyruvate
here's pyruvate and so
we showed last time we can take two
electrons
from nadh reduced that gives us
this hydride ion
which can
generate
lactate plus what we're left with
is
the oxidized form of the cofactor
nad plus
and now this nad plus can be reduced
back to nadh at the gap
dh step and the electrons from nadh
as it's being re-oxidized to nad can go
and take pyruvate
and reduce it to lactate so nadh gets
re-oxidized to nad
pyruvate now gets the ketone gets
reduced to the alcohol
as you go from pyruvate to
lactate opposite of what's going on in
the gap dh step
there the aldehyde is oxidized to the
acid
while nada nad plus oxidized goes to the
is reduced to nadh here nadh
is re-oxidized to nad while taking the
pyruvate
and re-reducing it to lactate
this by adding here allows us now
to regain balance across
the entire pathway
this step is catalyzed by the enzyme
lactate
dehydrogenase
often abbreviated ldh
and that allows
regenerating the nad plus
that's needed for the gap dh step
which allows us to deal with the
stoichiometry problem
of the entire pathway and so what
fermentation does for cells
is allows electron disposal by taking
the product of the pathway pyruvate
reducing it stoichiometrically to form a
reduced product
as shown here lactate and that allows
you to maintain
electron balance across the entire
pathway
and so this entire fermentative pathway
glucose to lactate
now allows the generation of the net
generation of
2 atp and
run this pathway in cells so cells can
maintain
a high atp adp ratio by fermenting
glucose
into lactate now
if you're paying attention this also now
begins to describe
why it is that oxygen is such a useful
molecule for metabolism and actually why
it's
quite key to supporting the
bioenergetics
of cells and so
recall oxygen was there when we burned
wood and we used that example and why
oxygen is so important for burning wood
why it's important for doing glucose
catabolism in our cells is that oxygen
is a really great electron acceptor
that is i can draw out oxygen
can take two electrons that are
generated
as nadh waste if you want to call it
that
plus
protons and this generates
water and so an alternative
to fermentation is what in order to
allow glucose oxidation
is rather than do fermentation is to
transfer those electrons to
oxygen to run the pathway another way in
other words
if we write glucose to pyruvate
and realize that this is an oxidation
reaction
and so therefore generates electron
waste in the form of nadh
that has to be recycled to nad
we can do so by putting those
re-oxidizing the nadh means something
else has to be reduced
this something else could be oxygen
as a good electron acceptor to be
reduced to water
and find an alternative place to put
those electrons
or if oxygen is not present now we can
do fermentation
turning pyruvate into lactate
it should be clear that if we want to
completely oxidize glucose
as in burning wood that is turn it
all the carbon and glucose into the most
oxidized form of carbon co2
this also requires
places to put electrons
that is we could generate more nadh
and of course each of those electrons
have to be dealt with
and the final home for those electrons
needs to be something that's a good
electron acceptor
like oxygen allowing you to continually
re-oxidize
your nadh by reducing oxygen
to water so in the absence
of fermentation oxygen can be used
to maintain electron balance
and of course much more energy is going
to be
released if we completely burn glucose
then if we only partially oxidize
glucose
and this is why oxygen allows more
energy to be released or
as you probably learned in high school
more atp to be produced
from glucose metabolism now the details
of how
all of this works are much more
complicated than
what i have drawn obviously fermentation
happens the way i drew it but all the
other details about the role of oxygen
and how it fits in
to these pathways is more complicated
than what i've drawn and we'll cover
this in the upcoming lectures
but the key concept is here and that is
the relationship between oxygen and
fermentation
is really what's illustrated here these
are two different ways
that cells can use to dispose
of the electron waste that's produced
from
carbon oxidation and glucose metabolism
those electrons have to go somewhere
they can go to the product of glycolysis
say pyruvate to lactate by lactate
dehydrogenase
reduce the pyruvate to lactate
fermentation
or they can go somewhere else a great
electron acceptor like oxygen
which allows these pathways to happen
while saving the pyruvate to do
something else like to be completely
oxidized
to co2 now it should be clear here then
that one of the things that's special
about fermentation
is that absolutely no oxygen is required
to do this
and this is part of the reason why this
pathway is so ancient
fermentation evolved in the pre-oxygen
atmosphere
and that really is why it's such an
ancient pathway
only when oxygen levels rose in the
atmosphere due to photosynthesis
that enough oxygen was around that then
other oxidative pathways could evolve
as an alternative to to fermentation
now you'll note that the original
description of fermentation by pasteur
was ethanol not lactate we'll cover the
details of ethanol in a minute
but i just want to point out that making
ethanol instead of lactate
is simply an alternative product to
dispose of pyruvate
as a more reduced product so ethanol is
a more reduced
product than pyruvate and that
ethanol generation is an additional
adaptation
that allows you to dispose of the
electron waste will also
generating a molecule that's toxic and
therefore allow
organisms that make ethanol to better
kill off their neighbors and their
environment and compete
for resources but the overall concept is
identical
ethanol is really an alternative to
lactate in fermentation but solves
exactly the same problem
i want to talk about ethanol metabolism
in more detail but before we do that
first i want to go through and just
describe at a very high level
some of the chemistry that allows all
these reactions in glycolysis to work
because you'll see that the chemistry
itself is not all that
complicated even though we can draw it
and it seems like somewhat overwhelming
when drawn out as a whole pathway
now i want to point out we've already
covered the chemistry for a lot of these
steps
first of all there's two dehydrogenase
reactions
there's gap dh and there's lactate
dehydrogenase
here's the mechanism for lactate
dehydrogenase as a hydride transfer
same thing happened at gap dh with the
additional details of adding the
phosphate
we covered that previously in an earlier
lecture
note we also covered before
the chemistry of pyruvate kinase and
phosphoglycerate kinase
in addition there's two more kinase
reactions that exist here
hexokinase and phosphofructokinase
these are really just straightforward
phospho-transfer reactions
using atp to transfer a phosphate very
straightforward exactly what professor
yaffi has already talked to you about
about how one does um phosphotransfer
for kinase reactions on proteins
now two other steps are isomerase
reactions
trios phosphate isomerase and glucose
phosphate isomerase we discussed this
chemistry back when we did the sugar
lectures
this is just acting on the open chain
form of the carbohydrate
and allows you to interconvert between
the ketose and the aldos
as i already drew during that lecture
and so that just leaves
a few steps left to discuss that we can
cover briefly
the first one that we'll talk about is
this
enolase reaction which is simply a
dehydration
i'll draw it here just to be explicit as
to what's
going on
so here is
two phosphoglycerate
simply dehydration to remove water
and that gives us
phosphoenol pyruvate pep
the next step i want to discuss
phosphoglycerate mutase is an example of
a mutase reaction that is remember it's
moving the phosphate
from the three to the two position of
glycerate this is a class of reactions
that has somewhat of an
interesting mechanism and basically
proceeds by a phosphorylated
enzyme intermediate in the case of
phosphoglycerate mutase this is a
histidine and so there's a
histidine with a nitrogen on it
in the active site and effectively
this nitrogen can pick up a phosphate
and be primed via
a reaction involving a molecule you've
seen
already from
your discussion of hemoglobin with
professor yaffi
and that's 2-3 bisphosphoglycerate and
so
again here's
this is glycerate phosphorylated on the
two and three position
so this is two three
phosphoglycerate and effectively this
molecule can
bind in the active site and pick up a
phosphate from either the 2
or the 3 position i drew it here as
picking it up from
the 2 position all right that would of
course
generate a 3-phosphoglycerate but more
importantly
it ends up with the enzyme having
this phosphorylated
intermediate in the active site
once it has that phosphorylated
intermediate in the active site
now it's ready to catalyze
the mutase reaction
so i'll draw here first this here would
be
three phosphoglycerate
color the phosphate so you can see
what's going on
this would basically in the active site
of the enzyme
pick up the phosphate
from the active site and generate
transiently
this
2 three
bisphosphoglycerate intermediate
and then it can retransfer
the phosphate from the other position
back onto the active side of the enzyme
so it's ready to carry out another
catalytic cycle and in the process
move the phosphate effectively
from
the three position to the two position
so you'll see
that the phosphate is not actually being
the same phosphate is not being moved
within the same molecule
it's being ping-ponged back and forth
off of this
phosphoenzyme intermediate and basically
this is how cells catalyze various
mutate
mutase reactions to move phosphates
between hydroxyl groups and so you have
to prime this
once with a separately generated 2 3
bisphosphoglycerate
but once you have that phosphorylated
enzyme in the active site
it can now continually ping-pong that
phosphate around
to effectively convert
3-phosphoglycerate
to 2-phosphoglycerate or an example of
another mutated reaction move a
phosphate between two other hydroxyl
groups on the same
molecule okay now the final
reaction that we haven't talked about is
this one the aldolase reaction which is
a really key step in glycolysis because
it splits that carbon-carbon bond
to take the hexose
fructose-1-6-bisphosphate
and split it into two trioses
dihydroxyacetone phosphate
and glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate which
ultimately
allows you to make this
pathway work and so
i'll take you quickly through how
aldolase
works so
aldolase also has this amine in the
active site
and so
so here's fbp drawn in the open chain
form
you
so end up with this intermediate in the
active site
which can undergo
this chemistry to split this
into the remove the
lower half of the molecule
so you can see here this
generates this lower half of the
molecule glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate as well as
the top half
a
you
which can regenerate the active site
as well as the
other product
dihydroxy acetone phosphate
and so very briefly that's effectively
the chemistry that allows aldolase to
carry out
this important reaction in glycolysis
splitting that fructose 165 phosphate
into the aldos glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate
and the ketose dihydroxyacetone
phosphate okay
so that is effectively the chemistry
that allows you to turn glucose into
pyruvate
as well as pyruvate into lactate but
what about
making ethanol how does that work
remember ethanol is an alternative
fermentative product
and so the reactions to make ethanol
is basically this
so here's pyruvate
first thing that happens is
we lose this co2
without a change in oxidation state at
the second carbon at the ketone in
pyruvate and so this ketone
stays the same oxidation state it's now
an aldehyde
this is a molecule called
acetaldehyde
and now we can pick up
those two electrons from
nadh
and reduce this aldehyde
to the alcohol
re-oxidizing that nadh back to nad plus
and generating
ethyl alcohol
or ethanol
so the fermentative part
is turning the acetaldehyde into the
ethanol because that allows you to
dispose of those two electrons reduce
the aldehyde to an alcohol
while re-oxidizing the nadh to an nad
plus
which is what allows glycolysis
to continue so that nad plus is
available for the gap dh
step how this reaction works
is i just drew it's exactly how the
lactate hydrogenase reaction
works however what we also now need to
discuss
is how you carry out this reaction this
decarboxylation
to take this co2 off of pyruvate and
make
acetaldehyde now decarboxylation
reactions are really common
um reactions in metabolism they end up
being
important for lots of pathways obviously
if we're going to
completely oxidize glucose into co2
we have to remove co2 for a molecule and
here's the first one
um first one that we're going to see
for how that happens now there's two
general mechanisms that metabolism uses
for decarboxylation reactions and i want
to introduce
the concept here of both of them now
the first one here is that these are
referred to as decarboxylation reactions
that occur in the context of either
an alpha keto acid
or a beta
keto acid now what do i mean by that
well
pyruvate is an alpha keto acid
and that's because here's a acid group
the ketone is alpha
to the carboxylic acid this would be
in uh
contrast to this
molecule which i'll just draw with a
generic r
group where here the ketone is beta
to the carboxylic acid alpha beta
so pyruvate is an alpha keto acid
this here is a generic beta
keto acid now i want to point out that
decarboxylations of beta-keto acids
are very favorable and they're favorable
for the following reason
and that's because if i remove
this co2 from a beta-keto acid
i'm left with
this molecule which hopefully you'll
recognize
as an enol and just like
we talked about for the pyruvate kinase
reaction
enols much prefer
to rearrange into the
keto form
and so decarboxylation of a beta-keto
acid
generates an enol which will rearrange
to the ketone
this becomes very favorable and so it
becomes favorable to decarboxylate
a beta keto acid now
we can't use that exact same chemistry
to decarboxylate
an alpha-keto acid however we can help
that process
effectively mimicking the same thing
that happens with a beta-keto acid
by instead introducing a cofactor
so i introduced the concept of cofactors
when we talked about
nad and nadh and remember cofactors
are molecules that provide functional
groups that help facilitate the
chemistry
of various reactions and so there's a
cofactor that facilitates the chemistry
that allows decarboxylation of alpha
keto acids
and that cofactor is abbreviated
tpp plus which stands for
thiamine
pyrophosphate
tpp plus which is derived from the
vitamin
thiamine sometimes also referred to
as vitamin
b1 and so
this is what tpp plus looks like
um
um okay
so like many of our vitamins or
cofactors it's a complex molecule so
this is
vitamin b1 or thymine and the
cofactor tpp plus is basically the same
molecule
with a pyrophosphate group added on the
end
tpp plus now to see what's going on
we're going to focus here just on
this part this reactive
this reactive part of the molecule which
is
right here which
for simplicity i will just draw like
this
okay so this here is just this
basically part of the molecule here
that's the reactive part of
tpp plus
and what makes this cofactor useful
is that this basically
can exist
in this
stabilized carban ion form
this stabilized carbanion can react with
a alpha keto acid
like pyruvate shown here
and then this intermediate
now becomes
favorable for decarboxylation of the co2
that's alpha to the ketone
and then here we can generally
regenerate
the active
tpp plus that we started with plus
the other product
acetaldehyde
and then that acetaldehyde can then be
reduced
regenerating nad plus
and giving alcohol for
fermentation okay
now incidentally this is how you
produce alcohol how you metabolize
alcohol
is effectively reversing that
last step and further oxidizing the
acetaldehyde
and so this is
this is ethanol
so the whey metabolis way ethanol
is metabolized and so the famous
alcohol dehydrogenase enzyme
basically
does that reverse reaction generates
two electrons as a hydride ion they get
transferred to
nad plus that nad plus gets reduced to
nadh as this alcohol
in ethanol is
oxidized to the aldehyde
in acetaldehyde and
this can then be further oxidized that
aldehyde
to the acid
so here again
two electrons from the hydride ion can
reduce nad plus to nadh and that
generates
in the process oxidizes the aldehyde
to the acid in this case this is
acetate
the acid form it would be acetic acid
also known as
vinegar and so effectively the way you
turn
alcohol into vinegar is by the
microorganisms
oxidizing the alcohol they produce
into acetic acid or
vinegar now note this is
alcohol metabolism is two oxidation
reactions
as we talked about last time oxidation
reactions are generally favorable
therefore energy is released this is why
alcohol has calories and it's impossible
to make
diet alcohol because it will
just no way around this couple other
things about this so as i mentioned
this enzyme catalyzes this is
the famous alcohol dehydrogenase this
enzyme is an
aldehyde dehydrogenase
the issue is is that this aldehyde
dehydrogenase
is a less efficient enzyme than alcohol
dehydrogenase
thus it can become rate limiting for
alcohol
metabolism and so if you overwhelm the
system by drinking too much
effectively this enzyme can't keep up
with this enzyme
you generate excess of the toxic
acetoaldehyde product acetoaldehyde
product
is toxic and this is effectively what
generates hangovers it's also the case
that there are individuals with
polymorphisms of this aldehyde
dehydrogenase
this was i believe discussed in
professor yaffi's lectures on enzyme
kinetics
that have different catalytic efficiency
at this step
and the people who have those
polymorphisms can't metabolize alcohol
as well
they tend to get flushing and whatnot
because they build up this toxic
acetyl aldehyde and in fact can be quite
dangerous if they drink
too much finally this
also illustrates effectively why when
commercially you want to generate
alcohol like in beer or wine
you need to keep oxygen levels low
why is that because well the microbes
will re-eat their ethanol it's a
perfectly good source of calories for
them as well
because of these reactions but they
generate
all this electron waste in the process
those electrons have to go somewhere
where do they go well oxygen is a great
electron acceptor
and so to metabolize this ethanol
they need to put those electrons
somewhere they need to put them on
oxygen
and so oxygen is required to carry out
this
ethanol metabolism by the microorganisms
and so by keeping
oxygen out of your fermentation of
alcohol and pre
in commercial beer and wine production
it prevents
the formation of aldehyde and
acetic acid products which would be
undesirable in your finished drink
product okay
now this whole discussion also
begins to suggest one big way in which
glycolysis itself is regulated and
that's
effectively by the availability of
oxygen and so to be explicit about this
i want to draw the relationship between
fermentation glycolysis and
oxygen in terms of maintaining electron
balance across
these pathways and so glucose
is of course a major fuel for us it's a
major sugar in our blood yeast
how use a lot of glucose from the grapes
in their environment plants of course
make glucose as a storage carbohydrate
it's
we discussed starch is a polymer of
glucose they can use this glucose to
survive the night
and effectively what they do is turn
that glucose into two
pyruvate molecules which can be used to
generate net 2 atp as we discussed
but creates this problem
that it also generates nadh
that needs to be recycled back to nad
plus
in the absence of oxygen you can ferment
that pyruvate into lactate
or alcohol or some other product that
allows you to regenerate
nad plus or
and this is a pathway that requires no
oxygen
however that pyruvate
can be further oxidized to co2
but that's going to generate even more
electron waste
that electron waste also has to be dealt
with
and that requires
oxygen or some other place to put those
electrons
oxygen to water being a major driver
of further oxidative metabolism
now the beauty of fermentation as a
pathway
is that no oxygen is needed
but the trade-off is that it's much less
efficient
you only get two atp per
mole of glucose that's two moles of atp
per mole of glucose that's fermented you
can imagine that a lot more energy is
released if you can further oxidize
glucose
you can generate therefore a lot more
atp if you use
a complete oxidation of glucose but this
requires
oxygen and so a major way that
glycolysis and certainly fermentation is
regulated
is that low oxygen
is what promotes fermentation
whereas high
oxygen suppresses
fermentation and that makes sense
it's intuitive you get a lot more energy
if you completely oxidize your glucose
you can more efficiently get energy from
your
your from oxidation of available reduced
glucose carbon
if you do it by oxidative pathways and
so therefore
in the presence of plenty of oxygen you
don't need to do
fermentation whereas if you outstrip
oxygen supply as say might happen if
your muscles are exercising
burning more atp than can be kept up
with by
oxygen delivery from the blood now you
switch over to a more fermentative
metabolism
something like lactic acid builds up
that can then be
dealt with later now this
fact that high oxygen can suppress
fermentation
is experimentally true in many organisms
in many contexts
it's likely because the high atp adp
that's produced with oxidative
glucose metabolism can
directly affect some steps or deplete
the nad that's required to drive
glycolysis
exactly the mechanism that causes this
is somewhat debated and likely depends
on context
and conditions but it also
sets out at least a way for us to begin
discussing
how is it at a level of individual
enzymes or reactions might something
like high atp
adp ratio affect flux or flow
through a pathway
all right well let's just start by
talking about what are the two things
that could affect
flux or flow through the pathway well
remember
thermodynamics delta g
is what determines whether a pathway
happens at all
and because delta g is proportional to
things like the atp
adp ratio you can imagine if this ratio
gets too high
some of the steps might no longer be
favorable to occur
that's certainly one possibility but the
other
way that regulation can be done
is actually kinetic and
this is because even though enzymes
don't determine whether a reaction can
happen
at least thermodynamically they often
time do determine the rate of their
reaction
and when we're talking about rate and
flow through past flux through pathways
flow through pathways
now rate can become very important and
so the kinetics of enzymes exactly what
you talked heard about with
professor gaffy properties like vmax or
km of an enzyme
which of course can be affected by
allostery and dr
and professor yaffi covered in great
detail these
also you can imagine can affect
how a pathway is regulated
and of course things like atp adp and
amp
as small molecules can be good
allosteric effectors of
some enzymes and so
let's now talk about if we're going to
regulate steps in a pathway
which steps should actually be
regulated and so shown here is again
coming back to
our delta g change map across glycolysis
as we alluded to earlier the steps where
it's hard to go back
is this hexokinase step this
phosphofructokinase step
and this pyruvate kinase step because
these are where there's the big change
in delta g
that now makes it hard to reverse those
steps
and it's exactly those steps that are
regulated
because that makes sense if this delta g
is thermodynamically driving flux
through the pathway
changing the rate of the enzymes that
catalyze those steps
is also going to change the rate at
which the pathway as a whole
can happen now as a result it's these
steps
hexokinase phosphofructokinase and
pyruvate kinase
that are often referred to as the rate
limiting
steps of glycolysis
personally i don't like referring to
memorizing things like these are the
rate limiting steps of the pathway
because in reality what step of any
pathway is going to depend on the
context
however often this concept of rate
limitation when people refer to pathways
really is coming from this energetic
argument about which steps have the
biggest drop
in delta g and it's important for you to
understand that not just
memorize what steps are rate limiting
now i also want to point out that these
steps actually are in
interesting places in glycolysis so this
is basically entry into the pathway
and this is exit from the pathway
and this makes sense too you don't want
to start
committing carbon into a pathway
unless you're actually going to need it
and you also need to match
output to input and what you'll see is
that many steps and pathways
that are regulated in addition to being
the ones with the biggest delta g
changes are also often the entrance and
exit from the pathway
which of course is the case in
glycolysis but also most
pathways and makes a lot of sense just
from
logical considerations all right
now if we're going to control things at
the level of
enzymes and rate how can we
control rate of a reaction that is how
can we control
enzyme kinetics well if you remember
from professor yaffi's lectures
you can increase the rate
of a reaction that is catalyzed by an
enzyme
by increasing the vmax of that enzyme
or if the substrate concentration is
close to km
by lowering the km of
that enzyme how can you decrease the
rate
of course you can do the opposite you
can decrease the v max
or if the substrate concentration
is close to km you can increase
the cam so how can i change these things
how can i
alter vmax or km of an individual enzyme
well there's a number of ways i can do
this one is is i can
make more enzyme
what will making more enzyme do well
effectively
that will increase the vmax of an enzyme
or if i get rid of enzyme that will
decrease the vmax
of an enzyme i can use
a different version
of the same enzyme that is have an
enzyme like
pyruvate kinase but have it come in a
bunch of different varieties have
different genes encode different
pyruvate kinase
isoforms such that those isoforms have
different
vmax and km relationships with respect
to sub
to to substrate and effectively by using
a different version of the enzyme a
so-called
isoform of an enzyme you can now
have different properties now you'll
note
that to change enzyme kinetics this way
basically is new transcription
translation
that's fairly long on the time scale of
needing to adapt to
metabolism but
that can work but sometimes you know
lions attacking you need to run away
quickly you may not have time to
make more enzyme you also need direct
control
of the enzymes and this is where
allosteric regulation of enzyme
function comes into play allosteric
regulation can be a result of signaling
phosphorylate acetylate and enzyme that
can change its properties
or you can have metabolite binding
bind atp bind amp
into some allosteric site that can
change vmax or km
and operate on a short time scale
to allow metabolism to adapt
in a more acute setting
i want to say that time scales matter
for real biology if you want to
understand
physiology and how it applies to how
metabolism and physiology relate to
biology that you'll encounter in other
contexts
you realize that some responses need to
be
acute those allow you to adapt to
conditions quickly
be able to get enough atp to run away
from the lion etc
but you also need adaptations that work
on longer time scales
because it's things like this that allow
you to enact programs that allow you to
adapt long term
to whatever new conditions a cell may
face in its
environment all right now
before i get into talking exactly how
these things actually work to regulate
glycolysis
i want to discuss a few details about
regulation of pathways in general
and while we talked about these with
respect to glycolysis these points will
end up coming up over and over again
and really apply to other pathways all
right now i may not explicitly point
this out
but they can same considerations for how
glycolysis works how it's regulated
has to be true for all metabolic
pathways and remember
any pathway is just variations on
relatively few chemical
chemistry reactions that are repurposed
in a way
to build some other thing that's useful
to the cell
and you'll see this over and over again
now it has to be true for every pathway
that it has to be thermodynamically
favorable
and that means either that the pathway
itself glucose to pyruvate
is thermodynamically favorable or
it's coupled to some kind of energy
input like atp
hydrolysis that allows the pathway to be
favorable
every pathway is going to be built in a
way that intermediates are generated
along the way that allow that pathway to
accomplish its goals in the case of
glycolysis
it was the two steps that allowed us to
synthesize atp and incorporate phosphate
despite the high atp adp ratio in cells
and in all cases this has to obey the
laws of thermodynamics that is we have
to obey constant
conservation of mass that we have to
count for all carbon
all electrons delta g has to be less
than zero
across the entire pathway you'll see
that the regulated steps
will often be those with the largest
thermodynamic
considerations like the big drops across
hexokinase phosphofructokinase and
pyruvate kinase
they'll often be at the entrance and
exits the pathway because you want to
regulate you don't want to commit
something to a pathway if you're not
going to use it
and you want to match input and output
and
all is going to have regulation that
acts on both short and long time scales
it allows it to
match um physiology
all right now with that in mind now
let's discuss
how we can regulate glycolysis using
both short and long time scales
as using really short time scales
allosteric regulation of glycolysis
in a way that makes it most useful to
cells
all right so the first step
is uptake of glucose
into the cell which in animals
like us is passive
but can still be regulated by
glucose transporters often regulated
glute proteins
and it's really these glucose
transporters that can often determine
whether glucose is actually taken up
into cells
a famous example of this is fdg
pet scanning which is used to measure
glucose uptake into tissues
in humans where basically a hydroxyl
group is replaced with a positron
emitting fluorine atom
fluorodeoxyglucose that is taken up and
phosphorylated in cells and it's this
lighting up of this on a positron
emitting
scan you can tell that which tissues in
the body take up glucose and that's a
property of cancer
and so is often used as a way to detect
or stage cancer
another example of this is insulin
basically one of the major actions of
insulin on your tissues is that when
glucose is high
your body makes more insulin that causes
glucose transporters to be put on the
surface
of your muscle and your fat which allows
that glucose now to get into those cells
and effectively allows us those cells
to dispose of the glucose in the blood
and keep glucose
in the right physiological range and so
uptake of glucose at least in animals
is one important step that is really
controlled largely by whether or not
there is a transporter
on the surface all right once that's
trapped as sorry once it's in the cell
as glucose hexokinase then
traps that molecule as glucose
6 phosphate and it turns out that
glucose 6-phosphate
is an inhibitor of
hexokinase why is that well we will see
in the next lecture that glucose
6-phosphate
can be turned into glycogen in the case
of mammals or starch in the case of
plants
and so glucose 6-phosphate if you're
going to store glucose you can ship it
off into glycogen
or you could commit it further down
into glycolysis but if you don't need it
for glycolysis
and your stores are full you'll build up
glucose 6-phosphate
you want to inhibit hexokinase to keep
things from flowing through
the system the next step
that's regulated is phosphofructokinase
so phosphofructokinase of course makes
fbp
the step downstream of that that's
regulated
is pyruvate kinase pep
to pyruvate and it turns out that
fbp will
stimulate pyruvate kinase
whereas pep will inhibit
phosphofructokinase
makes sense you want to match input to
output if you have a lot of fpp
activate the enzyme to dispose of it if
you're building up pep
tell you to stop sending molecules
down the pipeline it turns out
pfk is actually the major regulatory
step of glycolysis
because this is really what commits that
carbon to going through glycolysis
as opposed to upstream of that it could
be stored or not
so it's really that step that's the
commitment step
and so it's also regulated by some of
the outputs
of the pathway and so some of those
outputs
are atp
downstream of pyruvate which we'll talk
about later in the course or some other
molecules alanine
citrate it turns out that high levels of
citrate will also inhibit pfk
high levels of atp will inhibit
phosphofructokinase whereas
high levels of amp will activate
phosphofructokinase makes sense
a major output of glycolysis is to keep
the atp
adp ratio high the energy charge high in
the cell
if the energy charge is very high high
atp
shut off phosphofructokinase don't need
to do more glycolysis
if the energy charge is low high amp
activate phosphofructokinase if
production of other molecules
downstream like citrate are high come
back
and stop sending
things into the pathway turns out
alanine can inhibit pyruvate kinase
another step downstream
great this is effectively general
regulation
allosteric regulation of how glycolysis
works and what i wrote is was generally
true across different tissues but of
course these regulations
can be tweaked to be more or less
important to match physiology
and function now i know many of you are
going to take the mcat
and while i would never want to teach
just to take a test
a couple things that you should remember
for that test
is phosphofructokinase is a major
regulator
its big allosteric regulators are amp
as well as atp and citrate
whereas the other steps hexokinase you
should know that it's regulated by
negatively regulated by glucose
6-phosphate and pyruvate kinase
is positively regulated by
fbp now one other point that i want to
mention just because it will come up
sometimes on mcat exams is that
there's an additional detail about how
pfk is allosterically regulated
and that's because there's this side
reaction where fructose 6-phosphate
can be phosphorylated on the 2
rather than the 1 position to make
this molecule fructose 2-6 bisphosphate
this is a reaction that is catalyzed by
a bifunctional assay
enzyme called pfk2 fbp
ace so basically phosphofructokinase on
the two position
fbp ace removing it from the two
position
which allows you to regulate the levels
of fructose 2 6 bisphosphate
it turns out that pfk in glycolysis
which of course generates fbp is
positively regulated
by fructose 26 bisphosphate
and the production of fructose 26
bisphosphate
is something that can be inhibited by
atp inhibited by
phosphorylanopyruvate and
activated by atp so exactly
what is shown here is allosteric
regulation
just some of this allosteric regulation
is via
this side enzyme to make a separate
product fructose 2 6 bisphosphate
and there's control theory
considerations for why
that might happen all right
so at this point we've learned how we
can
start with glucose oxidize that glucose
via a pathway that now allows us
to get the energy that cells need to
maintain
atp adp ratio in a good physiological
range
um despite the high atp
adp ratio in cells
however it should also be clear that
in order for this to work we need a way
to actually get that glucose from
somewhere
to begin with you probably learned in
high school
that plants use photosynthesis as a way
to get energy from the sun
well the synthesis part of
photosynthesis is generating the sugar
that those plants can then use to burn
and keep atp adp high
at night and survive the night until the
sun comes up again when they can again
use energy from the sun directly to
get energy we as animals evolve the way
that we have to eat the plants we have
to get the glucose that the plants make
but of course we also use
generate have the ability to generate
some glucose
and this is best illustrated from muscle
physiology and that is we alluded to
earlier
that if we're running away from the lion
our muscles might outstrip the supply of
oxygen in the blood
and basically generate a whole lot of
lactate
while that lactate is perfectly good
fuel
just like the yeast can re-oxidize or we
can re-oxidize
ethanol we can also use lactate as a
fuel but it turns out a big job of our
liver
is to take that lactate from the blood
as well as other molecules and
regenerate glucose
such that our blood glucose remains in a
constant
level um level this cycling of glucose
and lactate across the body
between the muscle
and the liver sometimes referred to as
the cory
cycle and involves
a clear set of reactions to turn that
lactate
back into glucose a process
called gluconeogenesis
and unfortunately we're out of time
today
but next time i will start off the
lecture
by going through how it is that
gluconeogenesis
works to turn something like lactate
back into glucose so that organisms have
the glucose to begin with
to run glycolysis thank you
you